[Musique]
on
han
[Musique]
aujourd'hui c'était symbolique que trois
collèges de paris alice et de paris
quelque part failli ce livre leur
mémoire avec une pensée particulièrement
pour les lycéens du lycée français de
kiev ce lycée de kiev où aujourd'hui des
lycéens jeunes étudiants sont partis au
combat tout simplement pour résister
pour refuser l'abaissement de leur
patrie et quelque part c'est memorial
nous leur dédions aujourd'hui depuis le
sénat
[Musique]
m
il
l'école c'est la transmission comme vous
le savez la transmission du savoir bien
entendu des connaissances mais aussi des
valeurs et la grande mission de l'école
c'est de transmettre les valeurs la
mémoire et aujourd'hui il est
particulièrement important alors que les
crises internationales le secoue et
remue particulièrement la jeunesse est
très important de se rappeler que rien
n'est jamais acquis en terme de
démocratie qu'il faut être là qu'il faut
se souvenir qu'il faut être comme une
vigie et c'est très important de voir
cette jeunesse mobilisée aujourd'hui
cette cérémonie ça nous permet aussi à
nous de pouvoir nous exprimer et de
pouvoir va rendre hommage à des gens qui
ont peu et qui ont su s'exprimer à
chaque fois soit ils étaient obligés
soit il ya les leurs propres et pour
pouvoir défendre leurs république leur
patrie et donc pour moi aussi ça
m'inspire beaucoup
les toits
à
ras
m
[Applaudissements]
et voilà
ah bon
hasson
[Musique]
à